it's great to welcome to the program
today grace Blakely who is an economics
commentator at the New Statesman and
also author of stolen how to save the
world from financialization maybe that's
a good place to start grace when we say
financialization what what are we
talking about sure well I mean the the
technical definition is the increasing
role of financial markets motives actors
and institutions in the operation of the
domestic and international economy
basically what that means is bigger
banks bigger other financial
institutions hedge funds private equity
etc playing a much more significant role
in how the economy works as a whole so
it's not just you know banking and
finance being a bigger part of the
economy it's actually how the growth of
those industries changes the way the
rest of the economy works so you have
for example the financialization of
household finances the financialization
of firms and of corporate governance and
that really starts to shift how the
entire economy works rather than just
kind of being represented by the rise of
big banks and what's the effect of that
on the average consumer in the sense
that I mean we can imagine in a very
general sense if there are transactions
that historically were less frequently
connected to the financial industry and
over time become more connected and this
could be anything from you know as you
say household finance to auto loans to
day-to-day transactions using services
like square and stripe or whatever the
case may be and what is the impact on
the consumer of this yeah good question
so I mean in the book I look at and the
financialization of firms of households
and of the state in separate chapters
and the reason it's important to start
with firms is that as we've had the kind
of financialization of corporate culture
you've started to see a shift in how
corporations work and basically as a
result of the rise of shareholder value
ideology which is this idea that the
only responsibility corporations have is
to maximize value for shareholders you
size to see those firms kind of extract
more out of the economy and pay workers
less and distribute more to shareholders
creditors the wealthy etc and that's
kind of created a set
quite big problems in in the economy so
it's reduced businesses investment in
kind of building stuff so in production
and you know investment in things like
factories etc and it's also reduced
wages so you've seen you know in the US
and the average consumer an average
worker has the same purchasing power as
they did in 1978 in the UK we've had a
decade of wage stagnation and that's
been a trend that's that goes back to
the 80s really when they started
stepping up so you've seen a kind of
long-term decline in the share of
national income share of GDP going to
workers but what we've also seen as a
result of the growth of the finance
sector is that that's kind of been
concealed by ever-increasing levels of
debt private debt so credit card debt
mortgage lending etc and and by rising
asset prices particularly house prices
so before the financial crisis you know
your wages might have gone down because
of financialization of the corporation
but you might not notice because your
house was got rising in value and you're
able to access quite cheap and plentiful
credit which you know allows you to
sustain a higher standard of living even
in that context so that's kind of a big
way in which that's affected households
now of course long-term rising levels of
debt have not been sustainable neither
of rising asset prices so that was
really kind of integral in how the
financial crisis played out in the US on
the UK yeah this has such far-reaching
tendrils in a sense to really understand
this because you we understand what's
going on with wages as you point out we
understand what's going on with
inequality as you point out but yet you
still here in the United States anyway
it's particularly commentators on the
political right who say to quote Bill
O'Reilly some years ago the poor still
have big-screen TVs and cellular phones
and part of that is actually part of the
problem that you're pointing out which
is it's not that's not an indicator that
things aren't as bad it's actually part
of the indicator that things really are
quite bad yeah exactly
and I think you know what you saw really
in the 90s in early noughties was
accompanied by this massive expansion in
credit so mainly mortgage lending but
also lending and unsecured lending to
credit card lending and then
to purchase particular Goods it happened
at the same time as you had this kind of
new wave of globalization lots of
outsourcing lots of cheap consumer goods
available and this kind of really big
consumer boo and what that did it not
only changed the way the economy works
so obviously you had more people taking
out more credit to buy you know cheaper
goods that allowed them to kind of have
a higher standard of living even in the
absence of large increases in their
wages it also kind of changed like the
way societies worked right so this is
partly to do with the fact that taking
out lots of debt really changes your
your kind of psychology as a worker
right because you know if you're not
getting paid very much back in the day
you might have joined a union and said
we're gonna fight for wage increases if
you've got loads of debt and that's the
main problem that's kind of preventing
you from from having a good standard of
living there's not really a lot you can
do about that it's a very individualized
problem it's not you know something
that's quite difficult to kind of push
back against and yeah I mean it creates
also a kind of pervasive sense of
insecurity right because if you've got a
lot of debt and you're constantly on the
verge of not being able to pay that it's
you're much less likely to do something
like strike or will try and change your
job or really kind of be able to resist
the logic of the system in any really
substantive way so yes you know that has
been a problem for the economy because
people are taking out too much they're
often very high interest rates which is
limiting their spending power and which
will become a really big problem when
the economy turns which in the u.s. it
likely well in the next couple of years
but has also created a particular set of
political and social problems as well
yeah there's this we've talked before
about how the system in a sense is
designed to prevent people from having
the wherewithal resources and time to go
and really do the type of protesting
that would change the system because if
you don't have sick time or if you can't
afford to take a day off or if you can't
afford to travel to where the protests
are that is the system itself preventing
you from changing the system and in a
way
the companies that make money off of
making credit available are also
providing a means to artificially
inflate one standard of living such that
they might be less inclined to go in
protest because they're like hey I still
have stuff in the end exactly and this
whole model in in the book I talk about
privatized Keynesianism so you know the
Keynesian settlement was when the state
would step up and say you know when the
economy turned it would increase
government spending it would provide you
know basic basic necessities that you
need to live that you could draw on if
you didn't have a job but since the 80s
we've seen that kind of system of state
support replaced with basically okay if
you can't afford something take out debt
whether you know in the US it could be
medical debt it could be student loans
it could just be you know that used to
go on holiday or whatever so you've
really seen a kind of individualization
of economic relationships whereby you
know it's on you as the individual to
manage your debt manage your assets make
sure that you are saving enough for
retirement that you're you know insured
the you know you've got enough to pay
for your education etc rather than those
the burden of paying for that being kind
of shared equally amongst everyone and
yeah and as you say you know the more
individualized the economy is the harder
it is for people to kind of engage in
collective action and actually see you
know we're the majority here people who
live off work far outnumber people who
live off wealth and actually if they
pushed back against the system then
there would be real change and that's
obviously why in the u.s. there's such
concern about you know the rise of
socialism right there's people are now
something to push back against this and
this really kind of you know terrible
free-market ideology that's caused so
many problems but it's taken a while and
it's it's still taking a while for
people to actually realize you know we
have the power to change this stuff so
in the u.s. even among people who
believe that the degree of inequality is
a problem there is not a wholesale
agreement about how it should be fixed
there's progressive income taxation for
example but we know that that doesn't
include people whose income ends up
coming disproportionately from capital
gains for example there is
discussion of inheritance taxes now in
the Democratic primary there's the
discussion of different types of wealth
taxes Elizabeth Warren has proposed when
Bernie Sanders has talked about one do
you have strong feelings about the
policy proposals that you think would
not just most effectively but in the
sort of systemically most healthy manner
reduce income inequality and wealth
inequality yes absolutely so the wealth
taxes idea is it's a good one it's
something we're looking at in the UK as
well it is really important because that
division that I spoke about between
people who live off work and people who
live off wealth it's starting to become
much much darker so rather than just
looking at income inequality which as
you say it doesn't necessarily take into
account the ownership of assets if you
look at wealth inequality I mean in the
UK well some equality is doubly as high
as income inequality and you have some
owners if anything is more extreme in
the u.s. so wealth taxes are a really
important part of this and that can come
in the form of you know taxes on
financial wealth so on ownership of well
on capital gains as you said on
dividends but also you know property
people who own multiple homes or
landlords etc you know taxes on those
assets already important but in the UK
we're also looking at a kind of much
wider set of reforms to ownership itself
and we've got for example the idea of an
inclusive ownership fund on with the
Labour Party in the UK which is the idea
that workers would be given a kind of
steadily larger portion of shares in the
companies that they work for up to about
10 percent of the value of the entire
company which would allow workers to
kind of both own the companies apart of
the companies that they work in and also
engage in in kind of in the governance
of those firms we're also looking at you
know increased state provision of things
like housing so social housing and of
actively nationalizing some entities
like for example rail utilities etc and
what that would do is that rather than
kind of waiting for those who own all
the stuff to get very very rich and then
taxing it if we all kind of collectively
socially owned resources together say if
they're nationalized or if you know it's
a worker cooperative then when the
economy grows everyone automatically
gets better off and this kind of both
helps to reduce inequality but also it
helps to kind of democratize the economy
you're really trying to extend the
principles of political democracy into
the realm of the economy by saying
workers should be playing a much more
significant role in kind of owning and
running the firms that they work it
because they know what's going on on the
ground and you know firms that do this
sort of stuff often end up being much
more productive so to bring this around
a little bit to the current situation
and what some believe is sort of a
quickly approaching a global recession
of some degree
is there anything right now that reminds
you of the phase right before the
2007-2008 crash what one of the things
that does not seem similar is that at
least I've not identified a particular
market bubble that may be about to
collapse but I'm completely willing to
have my mind changed as far as that goes
but what are the indicators you're
looking at and what's your general sense
yeah so I mean we are definitely within
the next couple years heading into a
coordinated global recession because the
u.s. is likely to go into recession
within a couple of years UK probably
before a lot of it all depends upon
brexit and and Europe is already
teetering on the brink of a recession as
we speak and part of that has to do with
just the dynamics of the business cycle
so we get a recession we get a kind of
downturn in growth every 10 to 15 years
and you know it's it's since the
financial crisis we haven't had another
recession and so we're kind of do one
today so there's that there's also the
issue lots of issues around kind of
financial stability and and kind of
issues around the financial system so if
you look at China for example and there
is kind of a big debt bubble there and
that's potentially causing some could
potentially cause some instability in
the coming years especially as growth
slows in that economy if you look at
that
housing markets in Australia Canada a
couple of other parts of the world
you're actually seeing similar dynamics
there as you did before 2007 in terms of
rising mortgage lending the
securitization of that debt and not
being sold internationally so there are
a lot of pockets of concern there's also
corporate debt in the u.s. very very
very high and quite unstable and there
are kind of yeah sets of problems around
the stability of the financial system
with issues that haven't been results
really since the financial crisis so
what we're really likely to see over the
next couple years is a coordinated
global downturn in growth but that may
link in with some of these other
problems of financial instability to
create that particularly bad crises in
certain parts of the world and so yeah
particularly you know China the u.s. to
some extent depending on what happens to
this corporate debt bubble and also
Australia Canada places that haven't yet
had their housing bubble what if
anything can be done to mitigate the
seriousness of it or is it really that
nothing can be done and it has to be
written out the problem that we have
today really is that we have already you
know monetary policies or interest rates
already about as low as they can go in
most parts of the world in the US
they've been wrists they've risen a
little bit and that's at least partly
why you're starting to see some of these
problems emerge because it's made the
debt that a lot of these corporations
have more expensive so you know there is
scope to reduce interest rates in the US
but in many other parts of the world
monetary policy is about as loose as it
can be so be much more difficult to kind
of alleviate the impact of this
recession when it does come around and
that's also the case because we've had
obviously this program of quantitative
easing which has been an attempt to
loosen monetary policy even more even
when interest rates were effectively at
zero in many places and that hasn't been
wound up you know you know the u.s.
started to wind that up and it's causing
some real some real instability in
financial markets in the US so it looks
as though we'll be going into another
recession with big central bank balance
sheet so central banks owning a lot of
assets still through the QE program
and relatively low interest rates which
doesn't give you a lot of leeway to be
able to cut interest rates or
potentially do even you know another
round of QE right I think there's also
this other issue of you know after the
last recession governments stepped back
from using fiscal policy to expand the
economy so spending and taxes because
government debt was relatively high and
now government debt is still relatively
high at least partly because we haven't
seen that much economic growth in many
parts of the world over the last kind of
decade or so so really on a lot of
metrics governments are going to be
really constrained going into the next
recession and we might start to see some
unconventional things being done by
government so a lot of people are
talking about helicopter money this is
the idea that you can kind of create
money to give to households to boost
spending something that I write about in
the book is the idea of a debt write-off
so writing off some of this debt that's
constraining people's incomes and in in
the US and the UK in other parts of the
world absolutely fascinating and not
particularly optimistic but that is the
route we've been speaking with grace
Blakely who's an economics commentator
at the New Statesman you can check out
the book stolen how to save the world
from financialization grace I really
appreciate your time today thanks for
having me